[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
die vom sport hat rudi cerne hallo
schönen guten abend wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
weg bevor die russen kommen die letzten
noch verbliebenen zivilisten werden aus
den kampfgebieten in der ost ukraine in
sicherheit gebracht
teure energie wird zum sozialen problem
für gering- und normalverdiener schlägt
arbeitsminister heil ein jährliches
klima geld vor
die roten und
die weißen und das objekt der begierde
paris vor dem finale der champions
league madrid gegen liverpool
[Musik]
per telefon versuchten der bundeskanzler
und der französische präsident heute 80
minuten lang wladimir putin zu einem
waffenstillstand zu bewegen ohne erfolg
der russische präsident bietet nur an
den export von ukrainischen getreide zu
erleichtern allerdings nur wenn die
sanktionen gelockert werden zudem warnt
er den westen vor weiteren
waffenlieferungen die großoffensive in
der ost ukraine setzt er mit aller härte
scott lawton leihen muss
die seit tagen umkämpfte großstadt zirl
otto netztest offenbar kaum noch zu
halten erste russische einheiten sind im
gebäude am start eingedrungen darunter
die gefürchteten truppen des putin
treuen tschetschenen führes kadyrow
das bestätigt auch der ukrainische
provinz gouverneur und sagt unsere lage
wird immer schwieriger
noch haben wir genug kraft und
ressourcen um uns zu verteidigen
trotzdem ist es möglich dass der befehl
kommt uns zurückzuziehen damit wir nicht
umzingelt werden
es droht die einkesselung ins netz
ebenso in der zwillingsstadt charts denn
lehmann im norden ist bereits gefallen
ebenso partner im süden nur bach mut
wird noch gehalten
residenz liegt seit tagen unter
russischen dauerfeuer ukrainische
militärfahrzeuge verlassen die stadt
während soldaten und polizisten noch
versuchen die traumatisierte bevölkerung
in sicherheit zu bringen
es ist schrecklich so etwas wünsche ich
niemandem um gottes willen es ist zum
fürchten
einige evakuierungsaktionen auch in bach
mut nur wenig von der frontlinie
entfernt
die russen sind gleich da drüben und sie
kommen auf uns zu mahmud ist jetzt
hochrisikogruppe wir versuchen so viele
menschen hier herauszukriegen wie wir
können falls die ukraine abziehen müssen
ihr ziel der bahnhof von prof hier
fahren die flüchtlings züge in die west
ukraine
sonnenblumenöl getreide stahlwaren aus
der ukraine sind gefragt vor dem krieg
gibt es dort wirtschaftlich bergauf
jetzt aber bremst der krieg nicht nur
die produktion auch die exporte brechen
ein um über 50 prozent in der
viertgrößten stadt des landes in mikro
werden auch stahlprodukte für
deutschland hergestellt von den
problemen vor ort berichtet hannah
hebestreit
in nico ist das herz der ukrainischen
schwerindustrie aus dem takt geraten der
krieg hat auch das modernste stahlwerk
des landes und eines der modernsten
europas wochen lang stillgelegt nur
langsam läuft die produktion wieder an
ende märz haben wir angefangen alles
fertig zu machen was seit kriegsbeginn
liegen geblieben waren anfang april
konnten wir das dann wenigstens an
unsere kunden in europa liefern
in friedenszeiten beschäftigt das
unternehmen
10.000 menschen in fünf werken und um
die probefahrt vor allem kunden in
europa den usa und im mittleren osten
mit jedem stahlprodukten wie rohre oder
räder für die eisenbahn zu
beginn der kämpfe stoppte das
unternehmen die produktion fast 800
mitarbeiter wurden zum kriegsdienst
einberufen
wir stehen in ständigem kontakt mit
ihnen und versorgen sie mit allem
nötigen die schutzkleidung und erste
hilfe ausrüstung
wenn diese hochqualifizierten
spezialisten nicht bald wieder an ihre
arbeitsplätze zurück können trifft das
auch die eu mehr als jedes zweite
eisenbahn rat zum beispiel kommt aus der
ukraine und was sie jetzt noch im land
produzieren können wird zur
schwerstarbeit für die logistiker
unsere transport experten suchen ständig
nach wegen wenigstens europa zugeliefert
wir können ist nur per laster oder wal
versuchen
wegen der russischen hafen blockaden
sind schiffstransporte nicht möglich und
auch diese räder für güterwaggons
konnten noch nicht verschickt werden
kunde ist die deutsche bahn
krieg und inflation haben auch bei uns
energie und lebensmittel deutlich
verteuert mit einem sogenannten klima
geld für sozialminister heil menschen
mit geringem und mittlerem einkommen
helfen bislang hat die regierung schon
diverse entlastungen beschlossen so gibt
es beim verkehr den tank rabatt eine
höhere pendlerpauschale und das neun
euro ticket zu dem 300 euro energie
pauschale und die eeg-umlage beim strom
fällt weg bedürftige bekommen unter
anderem 20 euro mehr pro kind und eine
heizkostenzuschuss was minister heil
darüber hinaus plant dazu jetzt patricia
wiedemeier
erneut sollen die bürger entlastet
werden für untere und mittlere einkommen
sowie hartz 4 bezieher soll es ab
kommenden jahr ein klima geld geben als
ausgleich für steigende energie und
lebensmittel kosten so arbeitsminister
hey wir müssen auch antworten darauf
finden wenn die preise dauerhaft energie
und lebensmittelpreisen hoch bleiben und
deshalb nicht dafür dass für gezielte
entlastung für untere und mittlere
einkommen in deutschland organisieren
und ich schlage konkret vor die
einführung eines sozialen klima geldes
des menschen entlastet die keine oder
kaum reserven haben profitieren sollen
von diesem klima geld alleinverdiener
mit einem monatsbrutto lohn bis zu 4000
euro und verheiratete mit weniger als
8000 euro entlastungen in zweistelliger
milliarden-höhe sozial gestaffelt
finanziert aus der co2 bepreisung
während die grünen als vorschläge
begrüßen ist fdp finanzminister lindner
skeptisch in einem zeitungsinterview
sagte er da schulden und
steuererhöhungen ausgeschlossen sind bin
ich auf die finanzierungsideen gespannt
viel näher als neue töpfe einzurichten
liegt zudem dass wir für das kommende
jahr eine reform der lohn und
einkommensteuer angehen kritik von der
opposition es wurde versprochen eine
ganz einfache regelung 300 euro klima
geld für jeden vom baby bis zur oma und
was kommt jetzt raus eine regelung die
manche erreicht andere wieder nicht die
kompliziert ist und viele fragen
aufwirft der vorschlag des
arbeitsministers erscheint nicht
wirklich abgesprochen zu sein in der
koalition viele details ob wann und in
welcher höhe ist ein klima geld wirklich
geben wird sind noch offen
staatliche investitionsgarantien sollen
deutsche unternehmen vor politischen
risiken im ausland ab sichern jetzt hat
das wirtschaftsministerium zum ersten
mal solche garantien aus
menschenrechtsgründen abgelehnt für ein
projekt in china hintergrund sind neue
enthüllungen aus der provinz punjab
dort sollen mitglieder der muslimischen
minderheit der uiguren in
umerziehungslager
interniert sein genau in dieser region
waage die un menschenrechtskommissarin
war schlecht begleitet von heftiger
kritik es sei fraglich was ihr dort
überhaupt gezeigt werde und was sie
erreichen kann die usa sprachen im
vorfeld von einem fehler unter diesen
bedingungen überhaupt nach china zu
reisen
ulf röller berechnet
neue dokumente belegen dass brutale
lagersystem in st die schockierenden
fotos zeigen das ganze grauen im namen
der terrorismusbekämpfung
unterdrückt china die muslimische
minderheit
menschenrechtsverletzungen die die un
beauftragt die michelle bei chalet nicht
direkt ansprach knapp eine woche hat sie
die provinz xinjiang bereist
dieser besuch ist keine untersuchung
aber ich ermutige china seine maßnahmen
zur terrorismusbekämpfung zu überprüfen
um sicherzustellen dass sie
internationalen menschenrechts standards
entsprechen
sie sind die stimme der opfer
weltkongress der uiguren in münchen und
sie sind enttäuscht dass die un
menschenrechtskommissarin zu den
verbrechen schweigt ist wer den frauen
stabilisiert werden frauen in
internierungslager im gefängnis sind
gefoltert vergewaltigt und wer so
jemandem besucht und sagt gar nichts sie
müsste meiner meinung nach sofort
zurücktreten das war kein guter tag für
die menschenrechte aber ein guter tag
für pekings machthaber trotz
erdrückender beweislast traut sich die
internationale gemeinschaft nicht china
zur rechenschaft zu ziehen
diese gesichter klagen an aber die
menschenrechtskommissarin hat ihnen
heute keine stimme gegeben
harter schnitt zurück nach deutschland
und unklaren sonderangeboten mitunter
ist es ja nicht ganz einfach zu erkennen
ob das schnäppchen wirklich eins ist
oder doch nur ein lockangebot licht in
den preis dschungel will ab heute eine
neue verordnung bringen mit preisangaben
die besser vergleichbar und
transparenter sein sollen anselm stern
hat details
der ganz normale einkauf er wird immer
teurer der blick aufs preisschild der
preisvergleich immer wichtiger die neuen
regeln sollen dabei jetzt mehr klarheit
schaffen beispiel supermarkt hier muss
der sogenannte grundpreis der produkte
nun in liter oder kilo angegeben werden
bislang gab es da viele varianten und
wenig übersicht
verbraucher ersparen sich dadurch zum
beispiel zumindest den rechenaufwand
dass manche grundpreise auch in 100
gramm oder ähnliches angegeben werden
das ist in zukunft nur noch in
bestimmten ausnahmefällen möglich in
zukunft ändert sich außerdem eine ganze
menge in sachen werbung super angebote
tolle prozente ab sofort müssen läden
und online-händler quasi beweisen wie
stark die ware wirklich reduziert ist
sie müssen deshalb angeben was bisher in
den vergangenen 30 tagen der niedrigste
preis war schneller klar werden soll so
ob es sich tatsächlich um ein
schnäppchen handelt deutliche kritik
kommt vom handelsverband das alles sei
vor allem unnötiger aufwand
dass mit der neuregelung nicht mehr
verbraucherschutz war und ist aber viel
verunsicherung für den handel werden wir
den niedrigsten preis bei bestimmten
produkten die letzten 30 tage mit
angeben müssen dann macht es bestimmte
preissetzung unmöglich legt sie das
beispiel dass man 20 jetzt auch alles im
sortiment eine preisreduzierung geben da
ist es gar nicht möglich für tausende
von preis und das nachzuvollziehen
weniger preissenkung weniger
rabattaktionen mahnt der deutsche handel
verbraucherschützer dagegen loben die
neuen regeln kunden könnten jetzt
deutlich besser und schneller die preise
vergleichen und
wer noch mal genauer nachschauen will
welche neuen regeln fürs online-shopping
jetzt gelten der wird in der zdf- heute-
äpfeln dich
einen anti corona plan für den herbst
das fordern welt ärztechef montgomery
und lkw chef wieder die zahlen würden
unweigerlich wieder steigen so
montgomery und dann und es war um dann
bundesweit einheitlich entgegen steuern
zu können müsse das
infektionsschutzgesetz überarbeitet
werden inklusive lockdown option die
infektionszahlen im land sind wochen
rückläufig und damit auch die sieben
tage inzidenz aktuell liegt sie bei
209,4 meldet das robert koch institut
es ist längst nicht nur das corona virus
das die zahl der kirchgänger schrumpfen
lässt die katholische kirche steckt tief
in der krise noch nie kehrten ihr so
viele den rücken und der katholikentag
einst magnet für massen zieht auch nur
noch bedingt andreas linke mit einer
bilanz aus stuttgart
für fünf tage stand die stuttgarter
innenstadt im zeichen des 102
katholikentages
1500 veranstaltungen
vorträge gesprächsrunden konzerte
gottesdienste die die da waren genossen
dass es nicht zu voll war
so gestaltet dass man möglichst spiel
mitnimmt aber auch dann was mit heim
nimmt und das ist eben auf jeden fall
der fall ist dieser kraftquelle aber
jetzt nicht das gefühl dass besonders
wenig los ist sondern eigentlich dass
ich doch viele menschen zusammengefunden
haben trotz der widrigen umstände
rund 25.000 menschen nahmen teil ein
drittel der zahl des letzten
katholikentages in münster einen
rückgang der zusammenpasst mit sinkenden
mitgliederzahlen seit kurzem sind in
deutschland menschen mit mitgliedschaft
in einer christlichen kirche in der
minderheit
die unsicherheit die noch aus der
pandemie das sind dann auch noch nicht
ganz draußen was sortiert und wir sehen
auch und wollen das auch nicht negieren
dass inzwischen natürlich auch menschen
die lust verloren haben zu dieser kirche
zu stehen wir müssen ringen darum dass
es nicht deutlich weniger werben
am nachmittag in stuttgart
demonstrationszug der initiative maria
2.0 die sich für die öffnung aller
kirchliche ämter für frauen einsetzt die
wünsche nach reformen sind vielfältig
und der frust ist groß über deren
schleppende umsetzung und etwa über die
zögerliche aufklärung der
missbrauchsskandale mit einem
abschlussgottesdienst wird der
katholikentag morgen zu ende gehen
täglich sehen und hören wir berichte
über das kriegs grauen in der ukraine
sind entsetzt angesichts der zerstörung
und des leids doch was krieg wirklich
bedeutet das wissen nur die die es
selbst erlebt haben zum beispiel den
zweiten weltkrieg florian gottschick
über lebenslange ängste und wunden die
jetzt wieder aufgerissen werden
gebannt verfolgen peter und susanne
gallwitz die nachrichten aus der ukraine
bilder eines neuen krieges die bei ihnen
alte erinnerungen wecken das kommt
wieder hoch was da wie wir das erlebt
haben dass dieser bunten häuser und die
zerbombten häuser ja und und kontinenten
wiese auf der straße mit ihrem letzten
bündel und am arm gehen wie wir uns
schützen mussten vor feuer vor bomben
vor angriffen vor granaten die überall
flogen wie ihm geht es gerade vielen
älteren menschen die den zweiten
weltkrieg miterleben mussten beim bund
der heimatvertriebenen in erfurt hatten
sie lange nicht über ihre persönlichen
schicksale gesprochen jetzt ist das
anders
mehrere tierpfleger angriffe
die direkte ich persönlich erlebt ob
meine schwester ist vergewaltigt worden
die erinnerung sind leider wieder da und
es ist nicht einfach zu verkraften
sie alle waren damals noch kinder und
ihre tiefsitzende ängste lange nicht so
präsent diese erinnerungen sind ebenso
besonders abgespeichert die können
jederzeit wieder so aufpoppen und
richtig das leben beeinflussen also das
nennt man traumatische erinnerungen und
gerade solche bilder die wir jetzt eben
sehen im fernsehen können solche
erinnerungen trägern helfen könne dann
vor allem darüber zu sprechen so die
psychologin und abends einfach mal
abzuschalten um auf andere gedanken zu
kommen oder zumindest es zu versuchen
was in der regel ganz gut funktioniert
zum abschalten und auf andere gedanken
kommen ist der sport und vor allem rudi
muss vor allen dingen bei diesem spiel
heute das bietet sich an heute abend
geht es nämlich um den wichtigsten titel
im europäischen vereinsfußball das
finale in der champions league im stade
de france in paris fc liverpool gegen
real madrid zwei mannschaften gespickt
mit superstars das ganze live im zdf
jochen breyer in paris wer ist dein
favorit
ganz schwere frage rudi ganz ehrlich für
mich ist das ein spiel ohne favorit und
genau das macht diesen abend so
wahnsinnig spannend der fc liverpool ist
sicher das konstanteste team dieses
jahres gewesen hat im jahr 2022 erst ein
einziges spiel verloren übrigens gerade
mit dem bus vom hotel losgefahren in
richtung stadion ja und real madrid ist
halt real madrid der erfolgreichste klub
dieser champions league 13 mal schon den
titel geholt und in dieser saison allein
drei mal ein spiel gedreht was schon
längst verloren stehen auch völlig
verrückte art und weise also völlig
offen der ausgang und genauso
ausgeglichen übrigens das bild in der
stadt sehr viel rot sehr viel weiß das
wird ein sehr sehr stimmungsvoller abend
wir freuen uns auf ein großes
fußballfest und melden uns dann gleich
nach euch hier wieder aus paris mit dem
champions league magazin
prima wir freuen uns drauf dir viel spaß
also bis nachher die fußballerinnen des
vfl wolfsburg haben das dfb pokalfinale
gegen turbine potsdam gewonnen in köln
siegte die mannschaft von trainer tommy
stroot mit 14 0 für den vfl wolfsburg
ist es der achte titelgewinn in serie
die bilder gleichen sich auch im achten
jahr nacheinander die fußballerinnen des
vfl wolfsburg darunter die scheidende
torhüterin almuth schult stemmen den dfb
pokal in die höhe von beginn an lässt
das team von trainer tommy stroot in
köln daran keine zweifel aufkommen elfte
minute per kopf nach einem eckball zur
führung ein in potsdam eine passende
reaktion findet trifft die polnische
nationalspielerin nach etwas mehr als
einer halben stunde erneut per kopf 20
mit dem 13 0 durch nord ist die partie
schon vor der pause entschieden jansen
erzielt nach dem seitenwechsel noch dass
40 der insgesamt neunte pokal triumph in
der geschichte den niedersächsinnen
keiner frauen mannschaft gelang das
öfter
und die handballer des sc magdeburg
stehen erneut im endspiel der european
league im halbfinale des
final-four-turniers in lissabon gewann
der titelverteidiger gegen den
kroatischen club sechs sitze mit 34 zu
29 und schal erklärt hat sich die pole
position in monaco gesichert haben auch
noch die formel 1 gab ich danke dir sehr
dass sonntags etwa wünschte man sich
besser morgen wird es kühl und
wechselhaft details hat gleich christa
thoben in der halbzeitpause um viertel
vor zehn bringt sie marietta slomka auf
den neuesten nachrichten stand und wir
sagen danke und wünschen ihnen noch ein
entspanntes wochenende bis morgen können
sie mögen
[Musik]
guten abend der vorläufig kueste tag
steht uns morgen bevor zwischen diesem
tief über skandinavien und diesem hoch
über großbritannien kommt direkt aus
nordwest die kühle luft zu uns die uns
dann morgen temperaturen um 15 grad
beschert während auf der iberischen
halbinsel sommerliche 35 grad möglich
sind und auch nachts geht es bei uns mit
den temperaturen auf 10 bis 3 grad
zurück in der mitte gibt es auch
bodenfrost hier klar ist nämlich örtlich
auch sonst viele wolken in der nacht mit
einigen schauern der stürmischer
nordwestwind lässt aber so langsam nach
und morgen gibt es dann wieder diesen
eigentlich für april typischen wechsel
aus sonne wolken und schauer am
häufigsten sehen wir die sonne im
südwesten des landes teils auch im
lausitz umfeld die wolken sind richtung
norden und nordwesten aber deutlich
dichter als heute kurze schauer und
gewitter kann es überall geben am
häufigsten aber im südosten des landes
und von der westlichen mitte bis hinauf
zur ostsee und dazu gibt es eben diese
firma recht kühlen elf bis 18 grad
tageshöchsttemperaturen in der neuen
woche geht es dann schritt für schritt
mit den temperaturen bergauf bei
ähnlichem wetter haben wir dann am
mittwoch schon 20 bis 26 grad und es
deuten sich neue gewitter an genießen
sie noch ihren abend